حياكم الله يبدا الرئيس الصيني شيجن بنج
غدا الاربعاء زياره الرسميه الى السعوديه
وتستمر حتى الجمعه وذكرت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الزياره تاتي بناء على دعوه
من العاهل السعودي وسيشارك خلالها في قمه
السعوديه صينيه برئاسه الملك سلمان
والرئيس شيء ومشاركته ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان كما سيتضمنه برنامج زياره
حضور الرئيس الصيني لقمتي الرياضيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه للتعاونيه
والتنميه
هو تعليقا على هذه الزياره ينضم الينا من
لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير صحيفه شرق الاوسط
ناصحه في زيد بن كمي ومن العاصمه الصينيه
بكيني ينضم الينا الصحه في نادي رونج
مرحبا بكما معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياضه وابدا معك سيد زيد ما الذي تمثله
هذه الزياره للرئيس شيء الذي تمثله
للسعوديه في توقيتها في دلالاتها السياسيه
والاقتصاديه كذلك
المشاهدين
زياره الرئيس الصيني في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا حضوره هذه القمه همم سواء
القمه مع القمه الصينيه السعوديه او مع
دول الخليج او القمه مع الدول العربيه همم
تاتي في همم في الظروف الحاليه في ما
تشهدها ايضا همم يعني احنا بنتكلم عن همم
يعني العلاقات السياسيه لاصبحت الان همم
سواء من جهه الغرب او من جهه الشرق ايضا
وهذا الصراع اللي صار بعد هذه الدول
واهميه المنطقه
همم
واهميه المنطقه في السياسه الدوليه اعتقد
ان الرئيس الصيني زياره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وانا ايضا هي المحرك للدوله العربيه
ايضا كذلك يلتقي ايضا قاعده الدول العربيه
الذين سياتون الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه احنا نرى العلاقات الاقتصاديه
بين الصين وبين الدول العربيه ارتفعت
ارتفاع كبير جدا خلال السنوات الماضيه
واصبحت الصين لاحد الدول اللاعبا في
السياسه الدوليه المهمه التي تم المنطقه
وتم ايضا في حل القضايا التي تعاني منها
المنطقه سؤال في العالم او كذلك في
منطقتنا تحديد سيد نادر ما يهمه لكن ما
يهم ايضا في هذا الموضوع هو الجانب
الاقتصادي الذي يرتفع بشكل كبير جدا وصل
الى اكثر من 300 مليار دولار
في في الاهميه الاقتصاديه والاستثماريه
لكن سيد نادر همم قبل قليل همم سيد سيد
يتحدث عن ظروف دقيقه ربما حساسه همم يمر
فيها العالم بالنسبه للصين
الفرص الهدف الذي يبحث ايضا عن الرئيس
الصيني في هذه الزياره التي سيشارك من
خلالها في هذه القمه الثلاث
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذا الزياره والقمه تعتبر
مؤلما يعني تحمل اهميه كبرى لتدبير
العلاقات بين الصين والسعوديه وبين الصين
والدول العربيه
في هذا الوقت يعني تشد يشهد العالم همم
الكثير من الازمات وخاصه ازمه الطاقه
[موسيقى]
وكذلك الدول العربيه كذلك هناك حاجه الى
الصين
همم المساعدتهم في
التنميه الاقتصاديه بس همم اكبر همم
الدول العربيه منذ سنهوات وكذلك هناك ايضا
همم
الحاجه من دول عربيه الى الاست بعد
الصينيه وتسهيل التجاره الحره بين البلدين
وكذلك هناك ايضا همم امكانيه للتعاون في
مجال التكنولوجيا عاليه مثل الفضاء
والطيران وكذلك الطاقه متشدده في هناك
الربط لاستراتيجيه التنميه اللي في
السعوديه وكذلك لمبادره الحزام فريق من
الصين
هذه القمم هكذا مستوايا دائما ما تكون
السياسه هي من يغلب في هذه القمه لكن هذه
المره هل تعتقد بان ملفات الاقتصاد ملفات
الاستثمار هي من ستغى على الملفات التي
سيتم نقاشها في هذه القمه
واحنا نعزلها لان الملفات الاقتصاديه هي
محركات محركات الدول يعني في التنميه
والازدهار هذه الدول الملف الاقتصادي هو
مهم جدا لهذه الدول ااه اعتقد ان الملف
الاقتصادي هو الاهم من اهل لانه ايضا
تاثيرات ايضا سياسيه على المنطقه في نموها
وازدهارها والمشاركه في المشاريع وايضا
كذلك في الاستثمار المشاريع فيها في الدول
العربيه انا ارجع بقول مثلا المواضيع
الاقتصاديه او النمو المطارد في التجاره
البينيه بين الدول العربيه والصين يعني
وصل الى اكثر من 300 مليار دولار في
السنوات الاخيره تقريبا اضافه الى قيمه
المشاريع التي استثمرت فيها الصيني تجاوز
اكثر من 200 مليار طبعا من اهم الدول التي
لديها علاقه تجاريه بينها وبين الصين هي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لديها اكثر من
70 مليار او نحو 70 مليار تبادل تجاري
بينها وبين الصين اضافه الى المشاريع التي
تشارك فيها السعوديه والصين سواء كانت في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او تكون ايضا
بسيط احنا راينا في الزيارات التي تمت بين
القيادات السعوديه والصينيه سنوات الماضيه
واخر يمكن زياره الامير محمد بن سلمان
شهدنا توقيع عدد من الاتفاقيات التي همم
سواء فيما يخص الطاقه او ما يخص ايضا
البتروكيميكل او ما يخص ايضا كذلك التقنيه
والتكنولوجيا كل هذه الاشياء
هذه الدول دول دول يهمها مصالحها بشكل
اكبر جدا وهما ايضا كذلك انها تكون ايضا
في همم راكب التنميه والتقدم والازدهار
سيدنا نادر بكين كيف تنظر الى تحول
الاقتصادي الاستثماري الذي تغيرت همم معه
السعوديه من خلال رؤيتها الرؤيه التي
يقودها ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
رؤيه 20 30 اي الفرص التي تريد الصين ان
تستثمر فيها مع السعوديه او ان تقتنسها
ايضا في هذه الزياره
اه طبعا ارشحتنا يعني التطور الكبير
[موسيقى]
بعد
الطرح هذه الرؤيه رؤيا 2030 وهناك
الهام يحيى بمثابه السياسه الاصلاح في
الصين
فاتي النمور نسبه النمور القويه للاقتصاد
السعوديه ايمكننا ان نرى خلال هذا
العام يعني نسبه النمو في السعوديه تحافظ
على نسبه عاليه فوق
10%
والسعوديه ايضا تريد
الاقتصاديه ليس ليس اعتماد على همم
فقط
التنميه الاقتصاديه والصين لديها
الامكانيه
الجديده وهناك موارد الشمس
في السعوديه لديها ايضا
خبرات وتقنيه لاستقلال الطاقه الشمسيه
وكذلك اتوقع النوويه
باستخدامها بشكل سلمي وكذلك هناك همم
استثمارات الصينيه يمكن ان تساعد على
السعوديه وتقنيه الصينيه يمكن ان تساعد
السوريين في الانتاج الخطوط البناء وخطوط
الانتاج مع حاليا لتصبح
السعوديه الدوله الجويه منتجه كبيره في
المنطقه هناك حاجه همم الى بعضها البعض
وهناك اللي امكانيه لتعاون وتحقيق فوز
المشتركه بين بلدين طيب سيد همم
ايضا يبقى السؤال بشكل اوسع لا نتحدث فقط
عن السعوديه همم السعوديه ستستضيف ايضا
قمه خليجيه صينيه واخرى همم عربيه صينيه
كذلك هل ستكون برايك هذه الذين لاربما
شراكه استراتيجيه عربيه صينيه تقودها
السعوديه في المستقبل القريب
حقيقه اشوف ان السعوديه هي يعني
تنميه في ال- ال- في الاقليم او ايضا كذلك
في الدول العربيه وايضا هناك الدول
العربيه ايضا هي دخلت في مشروع طريق
الحرير اعتقد يمكن نحو 20 دوله عربيه يعني
تكون مشروع طريق الحرير همم تشارك فيه حتى
الدول الخليج لكن همم
كميه العلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه التي
همم بين الدول العربيه
من سنوات
مرتفع جدا جدا وهذا دليل على ان هناك
علاقه همم جيده بين الدول العربيه وبين
الصين اضافه الى هناك يعني همم
في مصالح التي تبحث عنها هذه الدول وتبحث
عنها اي تجتمع تجمع هذه الدول لتنقلها
ايضا الى علاقات استراتيجيه في المستقبل
واعتقد ان
السنوات الماضيه او كعلاقات سياسيه وايضا
اقتصاديه مع الصين اثبتت النجاح بشكل كبير
جدا
وهناك ايضا رغبه من الجانب همم السعودي
الخليجي العربي ايضا كذلك الدول العربيه
بتنميه هذه الشراكه همم بينها وبين الصين
سيد نادر هذه زياره تاتي بعد انتخاب شيله
لولايه تاريخها في الصين تاتي متزامنه
ايضا مع تصريحات غربيه تريد ان تضع
العلاقه مع الصين في اطار همم معين
بالنسبه لهذه الدول وهنا نسال شيء بعد
انتخابه لولايه الثالث هل تغيرت معها
اولوياته الخارجيه او لهويات العلاقه ايضا
شكل العلاقه كذلك ع- دول الشرق الاوسط
بشكل
خاص
اعتقد ان الصين ضلت يعني تقولي اهتماما
بالغه التي تتغير علاقاتها مع الدول
العربيه ودور الشرق الاوسط
والدول الشرق الاوسط دائما تكون من اول
غبيه السياسات الخارجيه الصينيه فهذا قد
اكدت اكدت حسين همم في مناسبات مختلفه همم
حاليا الرئيس الشهيد راح ايضا يتركه
البناء المجتمع مصير مشترك
الصيني والعالم العربي وكذلك هناك التنسيق
ومواقف متشابهه في الكثير من القضايا
الدوليه همم هناك دعم الدول العربيه للصين
في ما يتعلق بمناسبه الحيوان
والمساله الحقوق الانسان كثير من القضايا
وهنا ايضا الدعم من نفسه
للع هي في همم كذلك في ستار
سياساته وقراراتها المستقله وكذلك همم كل
الاحتراف تتمسك في عدم مبدا وعدم التداخل
في شؤون الداخليه شكرا جزيلا همم لكما على
مشاركه في هذا الحوار من العاصمه الصينيه
بكين اصبح في نادي وونج وكذلك من العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير الشرق
الاوسط والصحه في زيد بنكي